mado la niçoise est avec nous ce soir
applaudissements pour
vous n'êtes pas juste g1000 à l'ats beat
de chambre de bébé vous êtes magnifique
vous êtes magnifique mais oui parce que
je me suis lancé dans le showbiz bon
producteur il est là il martèle d'un
match de foot avec yodelice c'est pas un
sketch et que je fais monsieur dame en
moi je suis pas du shopping c'est je
vous fais une histoire que ça m'est
arrivé comme ça sur les idées toutes
faites
ce moment les idées toutes faites et
jaillit punch une chose tout le monde y
gagne c'est pareil au fait c'est le
mesclun gay et moi un jour mon mari il
invite à manger amazon de collègues de
la mairie tu sais monsieur mouloud et
monsieur david avec mes idées toutes
faites je me suis dit monsieur mouloud
et monsieur david ils veulent se
disputer sur la religion toute la soirée
en plus monsieur mouloud yvan muller
belge est halal et monsieur david evans
bull en belgique hier je me suis dit
matt d'autres tu fais ma fille tu
respecte les traditions culinaires de
tout le monde tu filmes poulets comme ça
tu feras pas de boulette
le problème va trouver un pool et une
moitié l'année l'autre casher ça existe
pas encore ou alors sur la bande de gaza
alors du coup j'ai commandé deux piliers
et de confessions différentes voies
alors à la main mais là j'avais le sait
que la livraison est gratuite passe avec
le halal et le cachet retient pas de
frais de port au moment de faire cuire
mais de poule et je m'aperçois que
j'avais une cocotte et avec mes idées
toutes faites je me suis pas fait
reculer deux poules et de conditions
différentes dans la même eau compotes et
j'ai pas envie d'être à l'origine du
conflit israélo palestinien
vous allez me dire on aurait pu demander
un cessez le feu
et même si c'est dans une cuisine très
polis cuisse de plus c'est bon vous dire
j'avais vraiment des idées toutes faites
et pas ceux des pouliches
ils s'en battent l'ale de cuir en sommes
dans la même content qu'il soit là le
cacher le ferment de bathory savaient
qu'ils viennent tous du même endroit du
cul doigt la poule f du coup il m'est
venu une idée allait en faire cuire est
chez la voisine
manque de pot mawazine et les
bouddhistes bouddhiste
arienne elle a pas eu la même verte pour
mon poulet elle me l'a carbonisé est
ramassé ce cas de ces fumées monter une
de ces bouffées j'ai dit mais en fait
vous que vous êtes bouddhiste quand vous
avez plusieurs vies que vous devrez
incarner pouvait pas ne rien gagner ce
poulet alors je sais pas si vous
connaissez un peu l'impasse que vous
avez des remises à la vous connaissez un
peu la philosophie des bouddhistes n'ait
pas les reins à ne même pas café
sciences po tous sens dans ce nom alors
je vous explique pas de se taire blaney
la comprimer les autres y verront
peut-être pas compris alors les boues
dix jours 10 pc des gens des gens comme
vous et moi à part que s'ils reviennent
voyez général on les reconnaît pas si
deezer revenez quand vous voulez y en a
qui sonne déjà revenu dans la salle et
ses rides et là une tête de revenir
n'avez pas bien compris c'est pas facile
d'atteindre simon grison fait ni simple
ni moi je veux bien faire dixième je
suis très aidée à me plaisent et de
total alors présent tu prennes type oui
par exemple tu dis tiens nous chez nous
on dit tu es né poussière tu reviendras
poussière et pêcheurs se nomme tuner
poussière et si tu y as bien réussi
table de boussières tu reviennes plumeau
et si tu as bien nettoyer ton karma tu
reviens aspirateur rue et tu peux finir
chef de la voir hier la mairie de carmat
[Rires]
je vous fais je suis désolé que voilà
c'est tu prends une petite karaté
s'habiller ça arrive un type la rate et
servile à une vie de merde banc mais lui
il risque de se réincarner un rouleau de
papier wc
alors messieurs dames la prochaine fois
que vous prendrez votre rouleau de
papier vayssié penser à ce type qui a
raté sa vie
essayez de pailhères rajouter une couche
non mais c'est on ne rajoute pas de la
souffrance à quelqu'un qui en a déjà ça
ça s'appelle la compassion c'est vrai
que je suis prête dans une émission que
c'est le moment de parler de philosophie
et mes jeux vous faire nôtre est un peu
plus simple messieurs dames comme ça
alors y'en a qui mange rien d'acquis
mange beaucoup de viandes inac image de
la vienne de rouge
et bien vous madame vous avez du sang
d'animal et qui coule dans mes veines
voilà vous allez revenir à 9 h et vous
allez finir au salon de l'agriculture
non mais chacun fait comme il veut une
fois comme lui et moi ça me fait souci
mais ce ne doit pas se moi je mange
beaucoup de poissons que le jeu doit
être l'année de mercure me suis dit
pourvu que je revienne pas de
thermomètre médical
non mais tu me vois m'introduire chez
quelqu'un que je connais pas les
fichiers dans le noir c'est pas une vie
y est alors ben nous revenons à nos
poulets avec nos moteurs à nos poulets
alors il me restait plus que mme boulet
quand ils sont arrivés monsieur
mouloudia que sa femme est monsieur
david avait que ça type a et qu'un
monsieur mouloud et il a dégainé la
bouteille de bordeaux et monsieur david
il a sorti les charcuteries corses quand
j'ai compris que j'étais tombé sur des
contrefaçons le thème j'étais drôlement
déçu et je peux vous dire messieurs
dames et ça monsieur david il a vu et et
c'est là qui m'a expliqué qu'avec
monsieur mouloud pas il était un ami
d'enfance depuis depuis d'enfance qui
s'avérera dîné ensemble dans le même
immeuble à oran voit que c'est grâce à
malouda sa famille que monsieur david
ils avaient pu remonter la pente quand
sa femme elle avait disparu c'était une
belle histoire que messieurs dames
j'étais c'était tout au bout l'évier
c'était quand tu sais comme un beignet
d'un dans un océan pacifiste
et bien ce moment là monsieur dans mes
idées toutes faites et se sont drôlement
défaite à ce monsieur mouloud et
monsieur david
non seulement ils éteignent halal ni
casher mais en plus il y avait quelque
chose que personne ne pouvait me relever
c'était leur amitié
ils savent amitié c'est la seule
religion qui te met tout le monde
d'accord
[Applaudissements]